[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN SEPASSI: Hi, all.
I'm here to tell you about
TensorFlow data sets.
It's a new way to have a
collection of public research
data sets.
It's on GitHub
and PyPI, and it's
ready to use with TensorFlow.
First, a little bit of setup.
Of course, this
is the partnership
that we all care
about-- data and models.
And TensorFlow 2 makes
it look really nice.
Set up your model,
your optimizer,
iterate through
your training data.
You get predictions, your
loss, gradients, update.
It all looks fantastic.
And they're good
together-- data and models.
And really, I just want to
focus in on this one piece.
This one line-- iterating
through your training data set.
In TF 2, with the
TF data API, you
have this really
expressive, simple way
of expressing high performance
but flexible input pipelines.
So we might start
with some TF data set,
and we can map, and shuffle,
and batch, and repeat--
build really complex pipelines.
And we know that this will
be really performance.
So this map call,
for example, might
be doing some complex
image pre-processing
on each record in the data set,
and it's happening in parallel.
You can see here,
num_parallel_calls=10.
So TensorFlow will be
spinning up a bunch of threads
so that this mapping is
really high performance.
And at the end, you also have
this ability to prefetch.
So as your tight model
training loop is going,
you can actually be
preparing batches,
ready to feed into
the next iteration.
Now, this is fantastic.
But unfortunately,
the source data
is a little bit out of step.
And so what we want is we want
this amazing, tight iteration
for inputs and targets
in train data set.
But, of course, what's hidden
from there is, how did you
get the data into a format
that you can actually
feed into your model
in the first place?
Every single source data set,
whether it's MNIST or IMDB
sentiment classification, you
have the IMDB reviews data set,
it's all a little bit different.
And of course, this
makes perfect sense.
When you're distributing
data at rest,
there's some natural format that
you'd like to distribute it in.
But we're not really
interested in data at rest.
We're interested in having
data in a format that's
sort of ready to move
into a TF data pipeline.
And what we really want is
something that's good together.
We want these two pups--
data and models-- to
really be simpatico.
And I'm happy to tell you that
TensorFlow Data sets is really
just about this one
piece of getting data
into a format that's ready to
move into a TF data pipeline.
And so here's
TensorFlow data sets.
You import TensorFlow data sets
and this load API for MNIST.
Because that's our
canonical first example,
always and forever, I hope.
We're grabbing the split
train, so the training split
of the data set.
We're asking for
supervised tuples.
So in this case, MNIST
is a supervised data set.
It has inputs and targets.
And so we'll get inputs
and target tuples.
We get a TF data data set
right back from the load call,
and we can build a
complex pipeline.
In this case, we're adding some
shuffling and some batching,
and then we're off.
Now we can iterate
through our inputs
and do all the modeling
things that we need.
And load actually hides
a lot of the complexity.
And so what's happening
here with load
is that MNIST is actually
being fetched from the source.
It's being pre-processed.
It's being put into
a standard format.
It's being documented with
statistics and everything,
which I'll show you in a second.
And then you're building
sort of the front end.
So you have pre-processed
data on disk, ready to move.
Typically you'd
only do this once
and, of course, TFDS will cache
all those results for you.
And then you're getting a
TF data pipeline out of it.
And we don't just have MNIST.
So ImageNet-- complex data set.
Most places, when you
go look at the tutorial
for how do I use ImageNet,
first step is, like,
run this batch script, muck with
the files over here, make sure
you filter out these records--
things like that.
And of course, this is
all taken care of for you.
Now, ImageNet is gated with
a password and username.
And so currently,
TensorFlow Data
sets just asks you
to download the data,
put it in a certain place,
and TensorFlow Data sets
takes it from there.
And we're actually
working with Kaggle
to get ImageNet able to be
auto-downloaded without having
any user intervention at all.
We go beyond images.
So we have text data sets.
So in this case, we
have IMDB Reviews.
Note, again, that the
API doesn't change.
This is just a tfds.load
call to get a data set.
So in this case, we'd be
getting the plain text
IMDB Reviews data set.
But of course, text is a
notoriously difficult format
to work with.
When you actually are
interested in doing
machine learning on it,
you have to do encodings.
And so we're actually shipping
with three really powerful
encodings.
One is byte-level, so you
have character-level encoding,
and another is subwords.
So we have a really great
subword text encoder
that was originally developed
in the Tensor2Tensor Library.
And so in this case, we'd be
getting IMDB reviews already
encoded into integers
using a subword vocabulary
with about 8,000 tokens.
So each of these data
sets is packaged together
as a data set builder.
So if you wanted
to add a data set
to TensorFlow data sets, which
I hope every single one of you
does.
I think there should
be about 1,000 new data
sets within a week.
That's my hope.
So Data set Builder is
actually really simple.
It does exactly
those three things
that load was sort of hiding.
The first, it has a method
called download_and_prepare,
which takes source data
out on the open web
or on local directory and
produces pre-processed files.
So it takes data at
rest and it puts it
into a format that's
data ready to move.
The second is as_data set.
As_data set takes those
pre-processed files on disk
and produces a tf.data.data set.
And the third is really
useful information-- metadata
about the data set, which can be
programmatically really useful.
So data set info is
the documenting object.
So in this case, it has the
features in the data set.
And each of the
features, you can
see, documents the name,
the shape, and the type.
So in this case,
the image for MNIST
is 28 by 28 by 1, type uint8.
The class labels, the
number of classes,
is documented in the
class label feature.
You also get statistics
on the data set itself.
What are the splits that
are actually exposed,
in this case, train and test?
And how many records
are in each one?
MNIST has 60,000 images
in the training set
and 10,000 images
in the testing set.
For supervised tasks, you
also get supervised keys.
So if you wanted to be able
to programmatically grab
a data set from TensorFlow
Data sets and sort of filter
for all the ones that are
trivially supervised data sets,
you can look for supervised
keys and pick out the features
that you need.
And for text, again,
one of these things
that's a bit annoying to work
with often, so this is IMDB
Reviews.
We see that it has a label
feature and a text feature,
and the text feature actually
contains the encoder.
We see here that it's
a subword texting coder
with a vocab size of 8,185.
You get the same
statistics for the splits.
We also support NumPy usage.
Now, this is
TensorFlow Dev Summit,
so maybe this isn't
so useful, but we
wanted to make TensorFlow
Data sets really portable.
And so you can actually just
call this tfds.as_numpy,
and it hides all the
TensorFlow from you.
And you pass it a
data set, it hands
you back an Python generator
over NumPy arrays, which
is great.
So coming back to
our initial example,
we had this beautiful
model and data.
But of course, trained data
set, where did this come from
and how did you
actually get the data?
And with TensorFlow data
sets, simple change,
and you actually have something
that works end to end, out
of the box, which is something
we're really happy about,
and we hope you are too.
You can come find us on
PyPI, the TensorFlow website,
and GitHub.
We have over 30
data sets already,
and there's more
being added every day.
The community on
GitHub has actually
gotten surprisingly active
surprisingly quickly,
so come join us.
We absolutely could
use your data.
If you're distributing
some data set
and you'd like to make
your data set famous,
please add it to
TensorFlow data sets.
It's a great way to make it
accessible to a huge community.
And come help us on GitHub.
There are data set requests.
You can help implement
a data set that's
been requested many times
or help us just develop.
We developed fully
out in the open.
All of our internal changes
are actually external changes.
We just develop
straight out on GitHub.
So thanks very much.
Hopefully, you guys find this
useful and come help us out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]